l' affaire villemin suite trois ans
après la mort du petit grégory une
nouvelle reconstitution commence
aujourd'hui la précédente dirigée par le
juge lambert avait été annulé pour
erreur de procédure
celle d'aujourd'hui est sans doute l'une
des dernières chances de connaître enfin
la vérité
roland sicard dès ce matin le juge
maurice simon qui est maintenant le
dossier en main a commencé son enquête
sur les lieux mêmes de la mort de
grégory villemin
une enquête qui va se prolonger pendant
quatre jours et qui pour le magistrat
devrait être une étape importante
en fait le but de la reconstitution
organisée par le juge simon est
d'établir l'emploi du temps de christine
villemin dans les dernières minutes
avant la mort de son fils pour la jeune
femme pas d'incertitude après être allé
chercher grégory chez sa nourrice
elle est rentrée directement chez elle
alors qu'elle était occupée à faire du
repassage dans la maison dagory qui
jouait dans le jardin aurait été enlevée
puis assassinée
mais le juge examinera une seconde
hypothèse à ce carrefour
au lieu de tourner à droite vers chez
elle et sylvie lemay a peut être tourné
à gauche vers la vologne
maurice simon va donc chronométré avec
le plus de précision possible le temps
exact il aurait fallu à la jeune femme
si elle est coupable pour aller
commettre le crime trois ans presque
jour pour jour après les faits toujours
pas de preuves décisives toujours pas de
mobile à l'assassinât du petit grégory
la reconstitution permettra peut-être
d'établir si christine villemin eu le
temps matériel d'assassiner son fils
elle n'apportera pas de certitude quant
à sa culpabilité le juge maurice simon
et pourtant décidé à poursuivre l'
enquête jusqu'au bout afin d'éclaircir
enfin le mystère de la mort du petit
grégory